what are you trying to do with your life
with your business what are you staying
for what movement is trying to create
most people don't stand for anything I'm
trying to help a billion entrepreneurs
when you stand for something important
it not only motivates you to get up in
the morning and go and work on it and
beat on your craft but it also helps
guide your decision making there's been
times where i've been offered
opportunities i've been offered
opportunities by companies who said evan
we want you to help us promote this
product and it just didn't feel right
you know like it again logically it
makes sense they're going to pay me tens
of thousands of dollars to do one video
but it didn't feel right because i don't
want to just be Hawking some product
because i hadn't clearly defined what it
was that i stood for so when you have
that clear purpose with your business or
with your life it makes those decisions
easier those things that you don't like
doing may not be aligned with your
purpose why are you doing these things
if you don't know what your purpose is
lend your wand all over the place but
you have these things that guide you
towards your purpose things that we do
get into the flow things that you do
enjoy where you like spending your time
and the way you need to focus more on
and not the things that are pushing you
away
you